meet soda pop an 11-year old boxer from
Maryland who recently turned into a
delivery dog for his owners winery with
the corona virus pandemic and social
distancing encouraged other dogs across
the country have also been put to work
including summit small businesses now
using their four-legged employees to
help safely deliver goods we tagged
along with a new york-based brewery to
see how their team has readjusted to
getting their craft beers on tap on to
local tables okay we've got your beer
three-year-old buddy and one-year-old
barley are known in Huntington New York
as the brew dogs their owners and now
bosses Karen and Mark Hewitt er own and
operate six harbors Brewing Company a
micro brewery on Long Island when I
first came out we were like holy smokes
can we open can we close what do we do
luckily for the Hewett errs their
business is considered essential during
the kovat 19 pandemic but it couldn't be
business as usual we've kind of
redefined our business we've never had
curbside we'd ever had delivery and now
that's all we're doing with the help of
the family dogs buddy and barley have
been requested on many cases and now
we're making it well known that they can
deliver beer to your house and I think
right now it's kind of helping a lot of
people on these deliveries because of
social distancing you really kind of
can't get close to people other than
your own family members the dogs kind of
brings that more of a connection for
them a kind of emotional support
delivery which the family hopes will
help keep the business going in these
difficult times the business is down you
know 60 to 70 percent of what it
normally is
so we kind of rile up the family you
know brought the kids in to help us out
in the meantime to do some canning make
some deliveries answer the phone and
drive traffic to their family breweries
social media letting
public know that six harbors is still
standing on two legs and four we're
doing whatever we could do to get
ourselves out there terrific
yeah thank you boys are we nervous yeah
I am nervous but hopefully with our new
options we'll be able to pay the bills
and make it go over employees the end of
the day it is a business and we have to
sell beer but when they go out and make
people smile I think people really like
that and in fact people need that these
days so when they put a smile on
people's faces they're doing their job
which by nature is easy for them thank
you for delivering beer and a smile we
will all take that now just I guess on
the other side of things I want to point
out six Harper's did have to furlough
twelve employees that were part-time
employees they're waiting for some PPP
money they're hoping they'll get it so
they can bring them back but what an
added dimension now having the dogs
Michele you're laughing how do you not
laugh and smile right I love it I love
it you know one of my neighbors the
Murphy's they need to start their own
business with Tommy the cat he's gonna
be a great neighborhood exterminator I
just have to say that it makes you smile
in this time right